hello everyone how's everybody doing
today oh please as good as I am I'm
doing fine got a couple of well I'm
gonna repeat a couple of out
announcements from last week the first
one is please notify me if you can't
hear me or my video goes out of work
I've had problems with that in the past
glad to learn what's the point okay
we'll find out what a point is today
maybe maybe we'll find out we have we we
haven't realized what a point is for the
last 2,000 plus hundred years okay and
I'm probably being conservative with the
number there anyways just a couple of
announcements repeating them the first
one is that we have our seventh rational
physics conference in borås Sweden and
here you can find it on the map if
you're interested in attending give me a
buzz at Bill at you stupid relativist
comm game or you can do it through Y you
can do it through this channel if you
want to put it in the comment section
and you can also do it through the
patreon page so there and also through
what is it our Facebook rational
rational science rational scientific
method page so there are several places
where you can sign up we're gonna get a
something rolling in the in in Facebook
as well right on this we're gonna give
you better times and so on as we go
along it's gonna be anywhere between
June 6th and June 9th okay
summer Sweden gotta be good and as
always you know we will have beer over
there for sure otherwise I would not go
okay so yeah you're invited everybody's
invited just come over and present
whatever Theory you believe you have
really it's quite flexible
so join us and see what you have to say
I mean there's a moment to ask questions
usually some of the people who get there
it says it's a small group and small
groups are kind of nice because you get
to really discuss things in in depth
with yeah usually people who think more
or less like you that that could be a
problem but see we don't think alike
in every field and when you raise that
different view we talked about
extinction over there we talked about
the economy you know history other
subjects are raised and it's it's a lot
of fun you know see what other people
have in mind
what you have usually guaranteed is that
you have intelligent people people who
think on their own they think out of the
box kind of and that makes it quite
interesting so in that sense you get to
meet great people anonymous people
people who are not you know you know you
know celebrities and of any kind but
it's good to to get together drink beer
discuss things it's a it's a good once a
year at the bar kind of reunion and you
get together at the bar and you
celebrate and you discuss things the
other one is this coming Sunday I will
not be holding a lecture because I'll be
on jf g's program okay and that she's on
Francois WP and he's got his
transmission the public space and I'll
be there and I think also peter has been
will be there I have not no confirmation
of that yet but he asked to be in there
I think he has been approved so more
than like you'll find Peter in there and
we're gonna be discussing black holes
primarily we might if we have enough
time we might get into discussing time
okay so that's gonna be on Sunday the
24th 1915
is Eastern Standard Time Philadelphia
time that kind of thing okay so we'll be
there and hopefully you go in there and
learn something about black holes I
consider myself an expert on black holes
me myself okay
other people don't consider me an expert
again if there are any problems with the
video or the sound please let me know
because in the comment section here
because I've had problems in the past
I changed computers and switched
computers that seems to have taken care
of the problem but I've not completely
become completely convinced yet okay
that's my thing by the way my companion
when I speak also clears my throat okay
first I want to do a little recap on
this issue of numbers apparently some
people did not understand some of what I
said last last couple sessions and I
just want to get the main points true I
want people to understand what I was
talking about what was I in attending
for people to understand okay and you
know this means you have to believe in
it doesn't mean you have to agree with
me I'm just saying this is what I'm
saying okay
this is the way I see things okay and so
just let's get that under under ahead
because some of the questions in that
popped up I'm gonna go over those real
quickly here showed me that some people
are not aware of what I was trying to
say
and I just want to make sure people
understand what I'm saying
not that they believe in it okay so here
it goes main points that I wanted to
make were these there are no scientific
definitions in the literature okay you
say well bill you're crazy what do you
mean we've been doing science for the
last 2,000 years for sure the last 400
years since the Scientific Revolution in
the 17th century you're saying we don't
have any scientific definitions
exactly that's exactly what I'm saying
I'm saying as far as physics is
concerned it's very clear we have no
scientific definitions we don't know
what a few of the main words used in
science today so-called science in the
scientific literature that gets
published in the journals and then gets
translated into popularization magazines
for the general public we don't know
what if energy is we don't know what
mass means we have no idea what a field
is we have no idea what time is you'll
look up the word and if you look enough
through the internet you'll find out
well finally a lot of people just throw
in the towel and say you know we don't
really understand what time is but let
me tell you my theory about time you
know so so they skip that important step
of defining what they're going to talk
about and they don't know what forces
they don't know what charge is and
that's in physics so called physically
mathematical physics I'm saying they're
not even doing physics in biology you
know what is biology to study of life
they don't know what life is they've
never been able to define the word life
they don't know what a living entity is
and they say well we don't know what it
is it seems like it's what it Brees when
but you know has babies you know
reproduces and and it goes through all
these what is it all these properties
and in the end they say well there's
always exceptions but let's continue in
the realm of paleontology they have
defined what a mass extinction is they
don't know what a background extinction
is I think these are two terms you need
to define very strictly very crisply if
you want people to follow your
presentation and so so we don't have out
there very well defined words they're
what I was talking with my son last time
their notions
not definitions they're not scientific
definitions that you absolutely need
within a discipline they're necessary
for the foundations of a discipline okay
they don't have they don't really have
you know crisp definitions that you can
put your hand in the fire for they have
notions they know yeah you know what I
mean and they just continue okay that's
that's the problem so no we have no
scientific definitions today and if
anything that's where my revolution
comes in I'm saying we have to define
words not because we're gonna do
semantics not mean because we're
engaging in philosophy or metaphysics or
we want to go in circles around in
ontology no the point is that you need
to lay the foundations for the
discipline that you're gonna be talking
about in which you're gonna be you know
presenting papers and dissertations okay
so that was the first one the word
number must be defined again to lay the
foundations of mathematics it's not a
trivial pursuit it's not it's not just
the spinning your wheels it's trying to
find something to lay the foundations in
this case of mathematics the word number
must be defined before using it in an
operation you know as an example also
you know like in physics you need you
absolutely need an object to do physics
if there are no objects in the universe
if you wipe out everything haven't even
nothing there no no stars no planets no
gases no atoms nothing no energy
whatever that is nothing in there what's
happening but what is taking place what
physics is happening in front of your
eyes well what are you imagining what
are you visualizing you need obtuse to
do physics and so the second mandatory
question on OA leads to it is what is an
object for the purposes of physics you
cannot avoid defining the word object
for the purposes of physics and nobody
has in the last 10,000 years but even
worse
nobody has real
how important it is to define words in
general and the word object for the
purposes of physics that's where we have
the problem that people don't even
realize that this is an important step
in mandatory inevitable one home type
step you need to define the the key
words of your discipline to lay the
foundations okay so so we're not doing
semantics here a lot of people dismiss
my argue the I are doing semantics you
you're beating up on words unique lay
the foundations I don't know how else to
convey that to you you need to do that
okay okay so what's the next one here on
the list the word number must be defined
before using it in an operation in other
words if you say 1+1 you're that's not a
number you say well what do you mean
it's the number two and the answer is no
the number two is a number but 1+1 is
not a number 1 plus 1 means that you can
you're doing an operation on already
what you defined as a number in this
case the number 1 you can say 3 plus 5
okay is 8 8 is a number 3 is a number 5
is a number 3 plus 5 is not a number
it's an operation performed on what an
at least two numbers that's what it's
not a number because you 3 plus 5 or 5
minus 3 is already an operation that you
that invokes involves requires two
numbers you have had to have defined
what a number is before you use them in
it's like the word object you know
before you use the word object in a
sentence in physics you're talking we're
talking about a dissertation a
scientific dissertation you've had
better define it what do you mean by
object you can't just go in there and
start using or the word energy you know
energy this we transferred energy what
do you mean you transferred energy
what's energy oh we don't know but let
me tell you my theory no you need to
define the words that make or break your
theory that you know in which your
district
is about and in a case of mathematics
and everything and taking whatever you
need to define the word a number before
you use it in this case in an operation
before you use it
okay some comment there but we'll skip
that for a second here the word number
is a verb okay that's my argument okay
that's my argument I'm saying that this
is what we've been referring to when we
say number for the last 3,000 years
every time we say the word number we are
referring to the verb to count we are
counting okay and some people say well
bill counting all you're doing is adding
units aren't you you're adding one to
the three and you end up with four you
add one to the four you end up with five
and so on down the line until infinity
right no no no no so let's listen
carefully to what I'm saying yeah you
don't have to agree with me I'm just
saying listen to what I'm saying we are
not adding units we are not adding the
number one to the next number in the
sequence okay what we're doing something
totally different we are moving our hand
this is this is a verb this is an action
you're counting apples you're counting
oranges you could be counting dreams and
abstraction so you're counting you're
moving the hand okay you moved it three
times okay and you represent that that
action with a number three with a symbol
called three okay if you do it four
times you represent it with a number
four with that symbol so we're not Eddie
we're not saying we're not saying oh I
know what four is four is three plus one
well four is also two plus two that's
two we need two numbers right and second
it's an operation so we already had to
have defined the word number before we
can use them in an operation and
officially use two of them in an
operation okay so I just want you to
understand what we're saying here we're
trying to define the word number for the
purposes of mathematics so that we
establish the foundations of mathematics
that's the context we are not adding
three to number one to three or a unit
to three to get four that's not what
we're doing we're moving our hand four
times representing that movement with a
number four that's what I'm saying
that's why I'm saying that a number
Alton Utley is not an M the word number
is not an M we that number that that
word is what we're using to designate a
symbol that represents a verb the verb
to count we are counting we are moving
our hands up and down we are not adding
we are not subtracting dividing or
multiplying we are counting that's what
I'm saying you don't have to accept it
you don't have the movie I just want you
to understand my position on this okay
okay and the last one here where is it
says the only numbers that qualify and
they're this definition are the natural
numbers and again because we're not
adding or subtracting keep in mind that
you know for example negative numbers
they already imply that there's another
number out there from which we are
subtracting negative numbers are already
in operation same for positive numbers a
natural number is not a positive number
a positive number means that there is
some number of their x from which we are
either subtracting in the case of
negative numbers or adding in the case
of positive numbers positive and
negative
already include the operation together
with the number that is being qualified
with that little extra symbol in front
of it the positive or the negative okay
so so let's get it straight the number
five is not adding it's not subtracting
it's a natural number natural number
means to count and I'm just trying to
say that that's the definition I'm
proposing as a foundation for
mathematics for the word number I hope
that's clear I don't know how how much
more clear I can make that okay you
don't have degree of the same please
understand me don't misquote me don't
and yeah I had some questions and now
you can see why I had to do this little
recap here here's some of the questions
that popped up okay some of you may
recognize yourselves in here yeah and
that's fine I hope to beat you up with
my baseball bat one fella said if a
number does not have a unit it's not
worth discussing 365 365 what well again
you know we're the answers my answers in
general there are in red okay we're
looking at the definition of the word
number for the purposes of mathematics
we're trying to establish what the
foundations okay 365 is a number 365
apples is not a number okay
365 apples is already you're already
applying the number to something else
just the number 365 out there the number
of times you shook your hands can be
applied to any object in the universe
you can be counting dreams like I'm
saying you know you can say 365 dream
365 apples or whatever whatever you
counted is not important the number
we're looking at the number only what is
the definition of the word number for
the purposes again to lay the
foundations of mathematics is a number
to count or account a noun well the word
numbers are now in in ordinary speech
I'm saying for the perp
of science for the purposes of laying
the foundations of mathematics number
really means to count it's a verb it
represents a verb the the number five
represents a verb of counting five times
that's what the number five represents
so counting is a verb the fact that we
represent it with a symbol like five you
know we can't do it you know like in
physics I keep saying you know because
this involves a little more here an
object is that which has shape a concept
is a relationship between two objects
you need two objects to form any concept
there you do you're your own thinking
out there looked at words in the
dictionary every word in the dictionary
which does not does not represent that
which has shape every word which is not
an object that's a concept what is a
concept concept is a word that requires
two objects okay so what happens what
happens the number five is a noun for
the purposes of ordinary speech in
physics only only that which has shape
they can be an object can be a noun can
be used as a noun
now the word five right the symbol five
is not really doesn't belong to physics
because physics doesn't deal with
numbers physics deals with objects
that's where we have our first
disagreement the second problem is that
yeah five is a number for the purposes
of mathematics but if we're gonna say
well you know can you move them number
five from here to there can you do a
physical operation on this thing no you
can you can use it in a sentence and in
that sense it's a noun but that's the
noun of ordinary speech a noun in
ordinary speech can be the word motion
and but we can't use the word motion as
a noun in physics you can't say the
motion moved the motion jumped you can
only have objects doing performing up
you know verbs are actions in
mathematics is right there in between
ordinary speeds and physics if we talk
about physics we can't say that number
five moved so the number five is a noun
only only from the point of view of
ordinary speech so in that sense the
number five is a noun but if we're gonna
talk about science we can't say five is
a noun
only object we have to use it the
criteria that we use in physics we we
have to say that five is a concept and
in this case the number five represents
the verb to count five times that's what
it represents so let's let's keep it on
the right context and again this what
I'm saying you don't have to believe me
you don't have to accept what I'm saying
all I was saying please understand my my
argument are you this is what I'm trying
to get through to you okay and so yeah
it's an the number five is a noun but
let's put it in the proper context it's
a noun in ordinary speech that is not
for the purposes of physics I can't say
that I moved up five from here to there
okay and if you move five apples you
move the apples not the five okay so we
are treating keeping track of movements
of your hand and using a symbol noun in
this case number to designate that last
count we are not adding again we are
numbering numbering is different than
add then adding right you can add three
plus five you can do that but you cannot
but but counting is something different
it's just sequential movements of your
hand okay that's all it is
and I just added there the reason people
confuse natural counting numbers with
positive integers is that they don't
realize that the former is an operation
performed on two numbers when you say
positive five
you are already implying the existence
of some kind of X out there from which
you are to which you are adding the five
negative numbers negative eight
you are already subtracting it from X
whatever X is X represents a number
so I'm just trying to get you to
understand the context of all this okay
and the way I see these things okay
there was another question another issue
raised by another felon I'd like to
answer these things because it shows
either that they did not understand me
primarily or that they have other ideas
and I want to criticize the ideas that
these people have because I want to show
that their notion of number is
unscientific and so if you're beaten up
if you come out bruised because bill
Goethe hits you with the baseball bat
the only purpose here is to learn you
know you don't have to agree but please
understand me so that you have a point
of comparison from your point of view to
my point of view okay that's that's what
we're doing here okay here it is
fella says here's a challenge for you
what is one minus zero point nanana Nana
Nana Nana and I mean all the way to ad
infinitum well we have to address this
word infinity again infinity is not a no
not a not a number okay
infinity is not a noun because again
it's not for the purposes of physics of
purposes of science we cannot say that I
moved infinity from here to there or
that it represents a place or that it
represents a number infinity just means
that you're counting incessantly that's
all it means
okay there's no object or place in
science known as infinity and the other
comment that I want to make because
relative it's like to use the word
infinity and they use this phrase finite
but unbounded what are they referring to
what they're referring to is that any
object they say you know really the
earth or usually they talk about
space-time because they're trying to
give up an idea to space-time they say
look space-time is finite but unbounded
okay there you have a little man going
around the earth okay so that you get it
the idea what they're referring to
what are they saying they're saying you
have space tonight what is space then
space-time apparently is this thing that
expanded from from ground zero which is
BIGBANG twelve point eight billion years
ago and it's expanding so if it's
expanding you know the image everybody
has is that it's finite that it's got a
some kind of surface where it ends and
something else whatever that something
else is continues so it's finite in that
sense and you say well then I thought
the universe was Infinite and they said
yeah it's also infinite finite and
infinite how can that possibly be and so
they use something totally different out
of the woods you know out of nowhere and
they say you can run around space-time
and come back to your place and continue
rolling around forever you know like the
little man here around the earth
he's walking he can walk there it is
he's walking he can go around the earth
he come back to this starting point and
he can go like that forever you can do
that around any object all objects in
the universe hopefully are finite and
unbounded in in a sense that you know an
atom assuming in atoms a little ball
right go around the atom you know as
much as you want it's gonna be infinite
in that sense it's gonna be unbounded
and so so we have to understand the term
that's why we have to define terms
because otherwise we get lost in the
conversation we say what is this guy
talking about okay and the finite
unbounded is is just a word wizardry
that's what it is it means you can run
around forever incessantly any finite
object in that sense so it's really not
finite but unbounded it's that every
object is bounded and you can run
infinitely around it if you want to look
at it that way the words are finite is
fine bounded is also fine but when you
refer you to them
it's not finite or unbounded or
infinitely it's incessant
we have to use a the right words here
you're running around incessantly you're
running around perpetually forever
whatever you want to use there so it's a
totally different notion than define an
unbounded object here's another issue
that was brought up let's see
you cannot change the definition of the
word number to suit you they're saying
you're accusing me of using these
definitions for my own purposes bill
makes up his own definition of number
and then deletes a list of numbers from
the number reality numbers are for
example the irrational little eye there
the e is Euler's natural log and pi and
so on down the line
and I just want to say to that that I
haven't changed the definition of number
because there isn't one like I said at
the beginning there are no definitions
in science and there is no definition of
the word number in mathematics that's
the issue the issues we have
I haven't replaced anything because
there isn't anything to replace we don't
have a definition and I'm saying - it's
the verb to count is this to suit my
purposes no I'm just really the
foundation of arithmetic of mathematics
I'm saying what have we been referring
to when we say number all these years
all these three thousand years we've
been referring to the counting we count
and that's that's what we call a number
wherever we land if we counted five
times we place that sail let's designate
this this five motions of my hand with a
simple five you know a little five that
we see every day and that's gonna be a
five and so everybody sees a five and
one a if you don't put anything behind
you don't say five trees five apples
what does five mean just five what does
that symbol mean it means that you
counted five times that's all it means
so five represents the verb to count in
that sense that's what I'm saying that
we've been doing all these years so I'm
not using it for my purposes I have no
purposes I'm trying to lay the
foundations of mathematics please
understand that
okay the other one is he says number is
a representation of a relation between
amounts and there we have the problem
see amount already is a number that's
what he's referring to so I haven't so
so ie
and PI are not numbers they are
operations that require two numbers in
other words a relation a relation can
only be between two things okay and so
someone said what is the most useful way
of defining number again the most useful
name is the one that serves the purposes
of the Foundation's mystery Illuminati
in other words you need to lay the
foundations of mathematics that's all
I'm doing here I want you to let's keep
it within context I'm saying if someone
says in the field of mathematics you're
gonna take mathematics in college okay
and you get there the first day you
never have mathematics in your entire
life you ask the teacher that the
instructor said what is a number well
what do we mean when we say number for
the purposes of math now for the
everyday stuff you know what people do
out there what is the what does the word
number mean the answer to that the word
number means to count because any number
any symbol that you choose to number 10
that number 20 that number 25 23 34 all
these are just how many times you moved
your hand that's all it is because it's
an absolute value
you haven't said what you're counting
and you can use it to precede any any
thing that you want to qualify you can
say five curtains for all I can say so
we don't know what you're gonna say next
we're just looking at the number five
what do you mean by five five means that
you moved your hand five times to count
the number of curtains that you got
there so so the five represents the
motions of your hand that's all it does
it's not adding a unit to it and it's
not adding a 1 to the 4 you're just
counting moving your hand five times and
we represent that with a 5 that's the
only context that I'm trying to get to
you and this is not to suit my purpose
is to try to establish the foundation
of mathematics if someone asks you what
the hell is a number okay that's all I'm
saying here and you don't have to agree
with mine definitely I just want you to
understand where I'm coming from on this
okay I'm trying to lay the foundations
of mathematics so that someone who asks
what is the number you can give them an
answers it's the verb to count the
number of times you've counted okay or
moved your hand or whatever okay let me
continue here moving on here's another
father who brought up this issue says
numbers represented is the
representational concept of a group said
lalalalala he continues well if you look
up the word set in in the Wikipedia says
a collection of distinct objects okay so
this fellow saying that a set a number
is just one of those objects in the
collection that's what he's saying and
in fact if you look at the Wikipedia it
shows that that little picture there
that you see it says a set of polygons
in Euler's diagram okay in an Euler
diagram and I'll give you those numbers
is that's green square there is that a
number as far as you're concerned now of
course not because a set is a collection
of objects not a collection of numbers
you can have potatoes in there is a
potato uh a number so a set isn't it's
an incorrect word to use to define the
word number because the set because all
this person says is we've already done
something with the numbers what have we
done well we've counted potatoes and
Apple we carried let's say vegetables so
we have different kinds of vegetables we
have potatoes tomatoes we have all these
vegetables in our set okay we had we
have five veggies in our set and so is
is a number one of those objects in that
set is it the lettuce is that what a
number is or is it the potato
so this is the problem the problem is
that the definition already in this
definition using the word set already
implies that you did something with the
numbers that's the problem with that
definition and again here you have that
he says they have been adapted for use
in subtle concept systems such
distractions and negative numbers well a
fraction is as you can see there there's
a fraction it's got two numbers it's got
a three and a four you're already doing
something with the number okay and the
other ones same thing you know negative
and positive numbers already imply an
anonymous number from which you're
subtracting or to which you are adding
so know that definition doesn't fly okay
I just want to make sure you understand
my criticism my point of view you don't
have to agree with it but just keep it
in mind what I'm just trying to say here
okay so here's the summary negative
numbers natural numbers fractions
division decimals multiplication powers
these are all operations performed and
at least key numbers okay and again any
number which is followed by some kind of
unit five potatoes that's not a number
five potatoes is not a number five is a
number potatoes is not a number so you
can't say five potatoes is a number you
can call it a value and I'm you can use
anywhere you want I mean I don't care
all I'm saying or a complex number or
whatever you want to call it all I'm
saying five potatoes is not a number
five is a number we don't use potatoes
as the numbering system and finally so
just want to make sure that we round
this up let's look at the third one down
pi is a ratio Oilers number two point
seven seven one eight natural log is a
decimal which means it's a different
form of writing a fraction velocity of
light it's already got a unit behind it
some kind of unit we're talking were
talking about 300-thousand potatoes
that's what we're talking about there so
potatoes is not part of the numbering
system so little C is not a number
300,000 is of number but three thousand
kilometer
per second no is not a number irrational
number of square root of -1 is not a
number it's already an operation
performed in this case a root on a
negative number the gravitational
acceleration here on earth 9.8 meters
per second squared again not a number
because it's got a unit gravitational
constant not only has a decimal point
but has a unit Planck's constant has
decimal point and a unit none of these
are numbers we can't call these numbers
because if we're gonna use the word
number consistently we can only refer to
the natural numbers then after that you
can do whatever you want you can qualify
potatoes or you can do operations with
two numbers if you want but the word
number means just refers to the natural
numbers that's where we should start
that should be a starting point from 1
to not infinity infinity means you're
still counting okay I'm gonna move ahead
here because today's dissertation at
least wanted to start it has to do with
the word point and once you know we
don't have a definition for the word
point either you would think you're
after uh what is it at least three
thousand years I would think gun not
only were talking about Euclid but
Euclid inherited some of the stuff from
from his predecessor so and and you know
the Greeks he inherited this already
from the Babylonians who'd even who
evolved from the or took it or stole it
from the Sumerians so so you know the
numbering system goes way back and for
all we know you know maybe the Chinese
developed it at the same time or maybe
earlier than the Sumerians Oh and we can
include the Indians there as well these
people have been doing arithmetic in
numbers for I'd say at least three
thousand years so you know I mean what
are we talking in fact uh the if you
look at the Code of Hammurabi that's a
thousand eight hundred years before
Christ eighteen we're talking about
almost four thousand
years you know it already includes
numbers it has how much things cost like
The Bookman takes you across the river
you got to pay him so much money he's
got that kind of detail in his in the
code and so you know you're gonna talk
about numbers then you know and I'm sure
numbers existed even before then when
they exactly started you know it's
anybody's guess so numbers have been
around for a long time and likewise the
point that geometry you know started at
some point they they had to move from
transactions when we went into
commercial farming from you know
subsistence to commercial we started
trading invented commerce they from
there on you know he said hey you know
by the way we need to find out if this
land is yours and for that they needed
to do some geometry you know this is a
square this is a rectangle this is your
land this is my land so they they
started surveying I guess you could call
it the land they had to know who owned
what partly because with taxes okay and
so yeah they applied it to geometry and
so geometry came into being and what was
the first important word of geometry the
word point and here's Euclid's number
version of point I'm sorry there's a is
he says a point is that which has no
part very famous definition what does it
mean well it means something like you
know the point is that which has no
dimension no size no no no no diameter
no volume okay
that's what he's trying to define there
well no kiddin so it's love I mean what
is the connect with the word love in
there love is that which has no part
yeah because I mean what size does love
has but what's the diameter of lone so
obviously you know we can't use this no
part definition to qualify a geometric
figure as the point is alleged to be but
that he in definition 3 he gives a
different definition it also
first of the word point says the ends of
line of the line are points so he's
going to have this notion where you know
a line extends between two points he's
also gonna say that where two lines
crossed that's a point so he's gonna go
through all this axiom an axiomatic
system where he's trying to find what a
point is but he never really defines he
doesn't start by you finding he kind of
starts using it he just says look a
point is that which has no volume let's
continue now you know when you cross two
lines it's a point the ends of two of a
line are points etc he starts using it
but he never defines what a word point
means fortunately were 2,000 years later
we must have a definition by now right
well not so here we have today's
definitions let's see we can find out
what these people have them done in the
last 2,000 years part refers usually to
an element of some set this is from the
Wikipedia called a space okay so a point
is a space but it says a point is a
primitive notion primitive means
undefined that's what it means
upon which the geometry is built meaning
that a point cannot be defined in terms
of previously defined objects okay so
you can go through the rest of that but
essentially what the wikipedia is saying
we have no idea what a word point is we
have we cannot define it that's what
they're saying because if you try to
define it well you're gonna need words
and you gotta define those words and you
know it's just an endless iteration or
you need other objects and there is no
more assumes no simpler object at a
point point is like the what is it the
building block you know that's that's
the brick with which you're gonna build
everything else and so you can't say
well what is the point made out of or
made of it's not made of anything
because it's zero dimensional it's got
no no diameter no radius no volume no
mass no any is just something which is
there and was which we're gonna build
everything else that's essentially what
they're saying
okay and let's see if if I'm just Peter
and you know nitpicky here but here you
find another definition this is from the
math forum they say more or less the
same thing the word point is often left
undefined in geometry texts no kiddin it
is it is pretty easy for us to
conceptualize a point but it is quite
difficult to define exactly
aha and he says it's an entity that only
one characteristic it's a position and
well it has no size color no anything
else so you know again these people have
this notion that you cannot define
certain words especially the word point
which is going to be the foundation of
geometry and you say you know so what
we're just gonna build this whole tower
on quicksand we're gonna go out there
and say we can't define the point we
don't really know what it is but let me
continue let me let me show you all of
geometry makes you kind of thing you
know we've been doing this for 2,000
years and you might say what we've done
well so far bill I mean look at the
technology we have that's not the point
the point is we're trying to talk about
science here we're saying we need to lay
the foundations in this case of geometry
and and if the foundation of geometry
the number one foundation is going to be
the point and people can't define this
term they don't know what a point is
they can't really put their finger on it
and they don't know maybe that's the way
you define a point but putting your
finger on it since they can't define a
point then you wonder you know is this
scientific it I thought the mathematics
was as one guy once put it some math is
about making definitions well yeah if
it's about making definitions why don't
you make one the first one that's what I
would say okay okay here we have some
more
here we have one site that can't
remember which one this one
this was the Malthus fun site it says an
exact location that's what it is a
location it has no size only position
okay and it says it has no size but you
can show it with dots you can put a dot
to represent this position this location
this notion there right and that they
have names like a and B and C whatever
and that's that's in other words they
start using it without really defining
the term they said that we don't really
know what it is it represents location
and it has no size but we'll we'll put a
size in there we'll put something that
has size like a thought so that we can
pictorially represent it for you so the
question is whether we're confusing the
dot for the location okay keep that in
mind that that's the question I'm gonna
be raising here keep that in mind we
replacing the dot are equating or
replacing home however you wanna look at
that the dot with a location keep that
in mind okay let's continue here it says
another given it says pointing geometry
is in location so he says flat out he
said has no size no with no length note
that a point is shown by a dot once
again so that's reinforced in this case
we're saying look the point is really
what we think of as a location okay but
location has no volume doesn't seem to
have any diameters or size or whatever
and we're gonna represent it with a dot
okay and then the merriam-webster
dictionary says geometric element that
has zero dimensions that dot seems to
have a little more than zero that means
it seems to have two in fact and a
location determinable by an ordered set
of coordinates they bring the notion of
of coordinates now in here and we're
gonna see a little more here here's the
this is Wolfram says a point is a zero
dimensional mathematical object whatever
mathematical object is to you which can
be specified okay in a dimensional space
using an n-tuple
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah coordinates
okay so again they're saying you know
you're gonna you're gonna represent that
with for example a ordered pair or
ordered triplet or whatever ordered
n-tuple and that's how you're gonna
specify it you're going to put these
parentheses and put all these little
letters in there saying each one of
those represents one of the dimensions
worth that you're gonna use or
coordinates to locate this point and
where's the point where the point is at
a location and the location is specified
by the ordered pair and ordered triplet
or the ordered n-tuple and so he says or
this comes from Erik Weinstein he's a
guy who writes this although the notion
of a point is intuitively rather clear
is it the mathematical machinery used to
deal with points and point-like objects
can be surprisingly slippery and he says
that you could have that problem in
again he represented it as a dot on a
figure one case a plane and the other
one of solid and he says that's a point
okay so did you get it let me tell you
what the problem is and please listen
please listen to what the problem is you
know I have to agree I just want you to
understand my argument against what all
these people are doing what they've been
doing for the last 3,000 years they
don't know the difference between an
object and a concept that's the whole
problem that's why they can't define it
an object is that which has shape the
dot that that can be two-dimensional or
three-dimensional be a ball or a flat
disk whatever you can think of a dot s
can also be it doesn't have to be a ball
to be a square or a cube for all we know
or a triangle in a cone okay so it
doesn't matter that's the object the dot
is the object the concept is location
not position
as they say but that's a long story I'm
not gonna get into that it's not low
it's not positioned the word is location
position is not location okay position
is the object itself that's why there's
no word position like position in
physics that's a concept that these
people have been using for many years
because they're representing the
position on a coordinate system where
they say you know what is the ordered
pair a comma B that's that's that value
there that's a little position of it
there and the word is not position the
word position in mathematics actually
actually means that you walked to that
point so position in mathematics is
really a dynamic concept it says two
feet to the right three to the left and
that's the position of this point from
this reference frame that's what they're
saying so position is motion in
mathematics I'm saying that for the
purposes of physics we use the word
location location is a set of distances
to every object in the universe that's
what location means so we're going to
talk about location which is a physics
concept that's different than the
position which is just motion for the
purposes of mathematics okay so what are
they saying they're saying they're
confusing the object dot which is an
object because it's two-dimensional if
you use the little flat disk on a piece
of paper three dimension of use a ball
they're confusing that with the concept
the abstract concept called location or
if they wish they can use the word
position in this case just for the sake
of argument position is not the same as
the thing is dot and of course they
could never reconcile these two things
they cannot reconcile dot with a
position object with concept and so what
has happened he said well you know we
can't define and we don't really know
what a what a point is we're gonna use
the word point why to use the word coin
why don't you use the word location why
don't use the word position that way we
have no no ambiguity if you say look
there's 500 positions on this line we
all understand how there's positions
there's a way we can locate a position
or location or whatever or we can locate
the position of an object on this square
or on this cube then we all understand
because we're not talking about point
we're talking about the position of an
object could be an elephant could be
whatever you say what is the location
actually but position what is the
position of the elephant in the zoo and
you say well you take five steps this
way three steps that way and you get to
the position of the elephant that's
where the where the elephant is well
then once you say position why do you
use this word point and mislead
everybody see what they've done in they
replace the elephant with a dot they say
don't forget about the elephant we don't
care about the oven could be a tree for
all we know we're going to represent
that object with a point because we're
interested in the exact location the
exact position of you know of that thing
that was there that we replaced with a
dot and so they're saying yeah but don't
confuse the dot with the location Kenny
locations is the concept we're trying to
get through to you but we're gonna
represent that with a dot what does that
represent represent the elephant the
tree that arrived whatever you pulled
out of there and replaced it with that
dot okay so so they have the dot the
object and they have location the notion
they're talking about and they try to
blend this these two and of course they
can never make sense of it and of course
that's why we don't have a definition
today and so here it is here's my take
on this math has to do with location
they talk about ordered pairs or ordered
n-tuples but what is that they're just
saying you know how the pirate has to
walk to get to the treasure chest that's
what they're referring they're saying
look you know we're talking about the
location of the treasure chest and in
that about the treasure chest and so to
say that the
treasure chest is the same thing as the
location of the treasure chest of or how
to get there that's that's wrong that's
that's what the problem of the word
point is the word point cannot be the
itinerary you need to get to the
treasure chest and also be the treasure
chest and that's the problem and the
treasure chest is what we would replace
with the dot and say well that's the dot
we'll call it P and that's the point P
and so so is that so can you define what
that is we said well you know I really
can't define it because the itinerary is
obviously not the same thing as the
thing you found at that location and as
you can see in physics it's very clear
if you put a dot on the board and you
called it the route and you use the word
point to refer to it the
extraterrestrial who's just learning
your language you can say okay I know
what a point is the point is a green dot
it's it's that circle that you put in
there you know that's what it means to
him you put up dot you say okay I know
what a point is it's that dot you can't
later on say okay now you gotta
understand something different every
time I say the word point I'm gonna
refer to the position or location of the
treasure chest you can't switch because
now you're not using your clients
consistently and there's a more
fundamental problem and it's got to do
with the definition of geometry that's
my last point here today here it is
what is geometry geometry is the study
of shape and size geometry was probably
first developed to measure the earth and
it's up and eat its objects okay
geometry encyclopedia of mathematics the
branch of mathematics whose primary
subject is spatial relationships and
shapes of bodies geometry study spatial
relationships and shapes while ignoring
other properties of real bodies you know
wait color and that kind of thing okay
so what is the problem here the problem
is here they say
what are the foundations of geometry
what are the shapes that we deal with in
geometry
well we deal with cubes with solids you
know spheres tubes etcetera so we deal
with solids we deal with planes so far
so good we deal with one-dimensional
lines totally unimaginable and we deal
with points zero dimensional points
actually non dimensional points why
because if a point is really though the
word point really means location
position it's non dimensional you don't
have dimensions and concepts love has no
dimensions you know physical diamonds
are linked within height what is what is
the diamond what is the the the width
and height of a point you know you
cannot apply the word dimension which is
related to objects length width and
height
you cannot extrapolate them and use them
to say love has dimensions three
dimensions that's okay in poetry but not
in physics and so what's the problem the
problem is that if you if point means
location it cannot be used as a physical
object it cannot be used as a building
block of geometry which as we just saw
is the study of shapes what is the shape
of location does it make any sense to
talk about the shape or volume of
location now these are words Weiser -
for objects so you cannot go in there
and say you know geometry is the study
of shapes we deal with shapes and
relations of shapes etc and yeah you can
say you can deal with tubes you can deal
with planes but when hold off on line
that's gonna be another lecture but when
you get to point you know what are you
if a point is location then you cannot
say that you're gonna build a plane
Square for example
you're negeb illed a sphere solid with
locations is that the building block of
a sphere a bunch of locations what is a
sphere made of locations that's the
problem we have the problem besides a
sphere should be a single should be made
of a single piece there should be known
locations inside it but you can put
locations inside it because it's not
made of locations because you're talking
about something else you're saying I can
locate a position and X anywhere inside
the sphere even though it's made out of
a single piece because we're talking
about enough stretch and we're talking
about you know locating with a set of
coordinates some location in there
you're locating a location essentially
that's what you're doing you're not
locating a point a dot because the
thought has no volume no no science so
to use the word point as as a synonym of
location in geometry you're not you're
not really referring to a building block
you're not referring to a geometric
figure a point location position is not
a geometric figure and as such does not
belong to geometry now if you're gonna
talk about planes and you said look I'm
gonna talk about locations along the
plane you know within a plane no problem
but don't tell me that the point is the
building block gets into your metric
figure and it's the foundation of
geometry now the foundation of geometry
really should start at planes which is
an abstraction already an ideal solids
which is another abstraction and then
you can locate anything you want in
there and you can talk about a series of
points locations which is what a line is
supposed to be you know then we have it
in the proper context but to say that
we're gonna start at point and we're
gonna start at line but we don't know
what these words mean that's what we
have up
and that's why they can't define the
word point to this day after three
thousand years they never figured out
that they're dealing with irreconcilable
concepts it's a is the analogy for God
is God the God of the Old Testament or
is God the God of the New Testament what
is the difference the difference is that
the God of the Old Testament is this
human-like creature with a magic wand
that creates the universe that's an
object the god of the New Testament
John's God it's a little different you
know he got his love got his spirit they
turned God into a concept 2,000 years
after the Old Testament you know in the
days of Christ Christian era Roman era
they turned God into a concept and they
started talking about God as an
abstraction and today you have people
who talk about God being intelligence
it's an intelligence out there you know
so so so we we turned poor God from an
object you know a flaming bush into an
intelligence in the abstract concept we
really did a magic trick on him morphed
him completely and this is what they've
done with the point they've turned the
dot into a location into a position and
he turned the object into a concept
that's the problem that's why we can't
define point anyways Sunday what is it
1900 hours Quebec time okay we'll be on
jf G's program I hope to see you there
you don't have to root for me you can
throw dirt at me I have no problem that
I received many rotten eggs in my life
in my face I'm so used to it doesn't
hurt me anymore so just bring it out
whatever you've got you know just bring
it on
we're gonna be discussing black holes if
we have time we're gonna do time if we
have time so we'll see you then we'll
see on Sunday at 1900 hours Eastern
Standard Time we won't have a lecture
because I'm gonna be on that program
we'll see you then bye-bye